oh that's finally do what everybody we
our pond phenotype and today we're
finding out just how much more difficult
it is playing with our left hand instead
of our right hands okay so with the
right hand around the net and through
the tape roll
[Music]
I think it went her symmetrize or it no
bad left hand I'm gonna get everything
no I don't think so
oh that was close it doesn't cut
[Music]
I'm making fun of my technique there
[Applause]
there look at the balls you thought it
would be like nine or something yeah
the next one is a target shot on a cop
let's start with the left hand it feels
like I don't have any control at all it
also looks like that
[Music]
or I thank for the right hand and I
think we should go within five shots
[Music]
Oh school definitely a lot easier with
the strong hand target shooting
[Applause]
let's see how well we can do that with
the left hand ah let's see if we can
even get two in a row and don't forget
to subscribe to help us reach 1 million
subscribers
[Music]
[Music]
oh that was okay
[Music]
[Music]
it's not as impressive as our right hand
playing but it's something okay five
behind-the-back shots in a row this
should be easy but I don't think it's
gonna be that easy with the left hand
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi this 117th five so we have to go
around these cups and land it inside
this one first try Oh be short
so close
[Music]
[Applause]
that's the one pretty sure that no oh
[Applause]
that was maybe 15 I'm pretty happy about
it
I think the lifetime is gonna be very
difficult for this one never try this
with life but I think it's gonna be near
100 let's see it's not enough spin
I almost want to get one right now
Oh what that's finally though I stretch
my recently won in for one hour after
try myself this is the one this is the
one it has to go in yes they protrude
like 600 times his son piggyback he felt
like you really have to learn again all
kind of spins and everything it's so
different with me with the wrong hand
and painful so I think it's safe to say
that our right hand rituals were a bit
better than I left don't forget to
subscribe to our channel here and watch
the previous episodes there until next
time